well after a very long time it looks
like we finally have some details about
Spider-Man 4 and just for the record we
are speaking about Tom Holland
Spider-Man 4 not a Toby Maguire
Spider-Man 4 although we will talk about
that in this video but this new report
that we have heard today is about our
mcu's Tom Holland Spider-Man however toy
Maguire should be making his MCU return
very soon a lot is happening with the
MCU right now and it looks like
Spider-Man is is going to be at the
center of it what we've heard recently
about Spider-Man is that he is going to
be the lead of Kang Dynasty the lead of
the next Avengers film now let's not get
this confused with the leader of the
next Avengers team rather he is going to
be the lead of the movie as in the main
star of the movie main focus of the
movie and if we think about it this
makes sense because he is actually
already had an experience with the
Multiverse but of course right now he is
not in a position to be the the leader
of the Avengers after all nobody knows
who Peter Parker is right now they know
who Spider-Man is Doctor Strange did not
erase the memory of Spider-Man from
everybody and that was proven in
Multiverse of Madness when he talked
about Spider-Man however Peter Parker is
gone erased from everybody's minds and
Tom hulland Spider-Man has quite a big
journey ahead of him in the MCU
especially in the Multiverse Saga we're
going to have Spider-Man 4 come out
before Secret Wars and then we're going
to have him be a big part of Kang
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars as well
plus he is going to go on into phase
seven phase eight possibly phase nine so
there's a lot that is about to happen
with Tom Holland Spider-Man so let's
break down this new report but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you can stay up to date on
Spider-Man and the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so today's report is
coming from Daniel rpk and he states
that Sony Pictures plans to begin
filming Spider-Man 4 in late 2024 now
although he does not specify which
Spider-Man they are going to begin
filming we assume it is going to be Tom
Holland Spider-Man because Marvel
Studios needs to get his movie out soon
and of course Tom Holland and Marvel and
Sony they've already confirmed this
they've already said yes we're doing
another Spider-Man film and recently
right before the strikes happened all of
the parties involved Marvel Sony and Tom
Holland said yeah we've met we've talked
about the script we've been over some of
the script and Tom Holland even said
that what he read so far he really liked
so we know that things have been in
place and have been planned for
Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland for a
pretty long time now and based off of
what we've heard from other insiders
Marvel Studios want Spider-Man 4 to come
out before Secret Wars and if you think
about all of the story that's going to
happen it needs to come out before
Secret Wars especially if you consider a
rumor that we have recently heard about
about how important Spider-Man is going
to be for Secret Wars apparently
Spider-Man is not just going to be one
of the main characters for Avengers King
Dynasty but he is going to be one of the
main characters for Secret Wars and that
is out of every Universe out there out
of the entire Multiverse you probably
have heard me mention many times on the
channel That in Deadpool 3 what we've
heard is going to happen is that the TVA
is going to be going around the
Multiverse saving specific heroes from
specific universes and putting them in
one Universe on one Earth kind of like a
battle world and although I'm sure some
will fight just because heads will Clash
but their objective in this is to gather
very strong Heroes to ultimately save
the Multiverse and take on Kang the
Conqueror and all of his many variants
the Council of Kings the main King Trio
and what is supposedly going to happen
is that Spider-Man is going to be one of
the main people that the TVA seeks out
to save from our 616 universe I however
once they save him he is apparently
going to team up with another Spider-Man
and some very Classic Heroes that
everybody is going to be super excited
about more than that in just a bit but
first big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you
probably know by now that I personally
use hellofresh a lot because for me it
simply makes sense I have a pretty busy
schedule in my day-to-day life and
hellofresh just makes eating good meals
a lot easier for me with over 40
different recipes that I could choose
from each week hellofresh does all the
shopping and meal planning for you
ingredients arrive at your doorstep
pre-portioned and ready to cook along
with pictured step-by-step recipe cards
they literally make it as easy as it
possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping right now we are
unsure if Tom Holland Spider-Man is
going to be the only person saved from
the 616 universe or if more Heroes will
be saved with him now of course it would
make sense that other heroes are going
to be saved with him however at this
point we don't really know much about
Avengers Secret Wars but what we have
heard from some insiders is that what
goes down in Deadpool 3 ultimately leads
to a multiversal Avengers team in
Avengers Secret Wars a team that it
looks like Tom Holland Spider-Man is
going to be on alongside Toby Maguire
Spider-Man from what we've heard about
the multiversal Avengers team we know
that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is going
to be a part of it he's not just coming
back for Deadpool 3 but he's in this
until the end of the Multiverse Saga so
he's going to play a main part we've
heard that Toby Maguire is indeed coming
back as well going to Star alongside
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and this is
going to be super super big fan service
to everybody who grew up watching X-Men
and Spider-Man in the 2000s right when
they came out same with everybody who
watched the Animated Series as kids this
is going to be epic and from what we've
heard Deadpool is going to be right
there alongside of them since Deadpool
and Wolverine are coming basically from
the same place and we've also heard of
course that there are going to be some
X-Men characters who are going to be a
part of this team as well and then of
course there should be characters that
we have no idea are going to be coming
in secret Wars because literally
anything is possible we've talked about
this several times but literally
anything is possible with the Multiverse
now of course you might have heard that
Marvel Studios seems to be planning for
a soft reboot after Avengers Secret Wars
and this is where things get kind of
confusing because we don't know the
exact way that the main MCU universe or
the Multiverse in general is going to be
rebooted so our biggest question right
now is if they take only Tom Holland
Spider-Man man from the 616 Universe
what happens to the 616 Universe after
the soft reboot and everybody aart of
that Universe well basically the good
news that we know about that is that
according to the writers of the book MCU
the reign of Marvel Studios basically
Kevin foge is using this soft reboot to
pick and choose what is working and what
is not working so essentially he's going
to go through the shows the characters
the movies and decide well this
character is going to stick around for
the next part of the MCU this character
sticking around for phase seven this one
as well but these are not and we don't
know if that's going to be a completely
new universe or our universe but
something happened to it and some people
are all of a sudden missing and pruned
but what we do know is that Spider-Man
is indeed going to survive the soft
reboot because what we've heard is Tom
Holland has signed a six project deal so
we have Spiderman 4 5 and six Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
and one that we don't actually know yet
so Spider-Man 4 the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars that's all a part of the
Multiverse Saga but Spider-Man 5 and six
and possibly the other project are going
to take place after the Multiverse Saga
ends so that's great news because no
matter what happens after the soft
reboot we know that Tom Holland
Spider-Man is going to be there in our
new universe in Phase seven or phase one
maybe if they decide to completely start
over from the beginning whatever it is
Tom Holland Spider-Man is going to be
there his future is super bright in the
MCU and it does s like Marvel Studios
wants him wants Tom Holland as
Spider-Man to lead the mcu's future
which if they had to pick One Singular
character to focus on he's a pretty
great character but we do know that
other people are going to be surviving
as well but the future of Spider-Man is
very bright so go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date with the MCU you can also find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof